alright and here's the solution to start
off let's look at our forecast fragment
query since it's a join between two
tables it's really easy for us to add
additional parameters to our query now
we make sure we keep the column indices
consistent now we've grabbed the
latitude and longitude at the same time
we're grabbing our weather entries the
next thing to do is to move the function
open preferred location in math over to
forecastfragment
instead of using shared preferences to
get these values we can actually get the
cursor from the forecast adapter we can
get our cursor move to a reasonable
position and then build our new string
which is just latitude : longitude we'll
leave our comment where it was finally
we just have to fix up a few things in
the code and that's it well at least for
the code we still need to do some work
in XML let's move this r dot ID dot
action map now over to forecast fragment
inside of it on options item selected
and now we've netted you some xml work
let's look at our main menu we'll just
pull this action map item out and we'll
place it right into forecast fragment
alright one more thing to do while we're
here one of the things rato talked about
was wanting to get rid of the refresh
menu item so let's just comment it out
when we remove that action refresh item
we should probably comment it out from
our source code too after all you never
know when you wanted to use that for
debugging so there we have it our final
app no longer having a refresh button
with a new exciting setting to turn off
and on weather notifications details are
taken care of I hope you've enjoyed
building sunshine there's still lots of
things left to do in sunshine for
example we could also add a lot more
intelligent things to its user interface
and of course we could make it a lot
smarter about syncing data and I hope
the practices you've learned building
sunshine will help you in all of your
future applications